now we have
robert cruz
who's going to talk about an analysis
of a provider survey which many here in
this room participated in
looking at prevention services for men
of sex with men
okay
thank you leaf
good morning everyone as chris uh just
mentioned last fall i was charged by the
department of public health to conduct a
provider survey survey on hiv sti
services for msm in connecticut
the department of public health aids and
chronic disease section initiative is to
respond to the significant higher
incidence
of hiv sti infections among men who have
sex with men as well as significant
numbers of co-infections and to respond
to the need for more prevention
interventions directly targeting msm
the goals of this assessment were to
conduct an analysis among providers
focusing on perceived prevention needs
barriers successes challenges and
perceptions of capacity related to
providing hiv prevention services to msm
in connecticut and to identify capacity
building assistance and training needs
of providers to help ensure
more hiv prevention services for msm in
connecticut in the future
the design of the survey and analysis
was as follows
interviews were held with 16 providers
across the state of connecticut
who provided their professional opinions
about msm hiv sti prevention topics
16 providers across the state of
connecticut
13 of these were dph funded hiv
prevention contractors
two were health care providers that
specialize in hiv care
and one was an academic research
institution
frequency analysis were conducted
there were 19 open-ended questions
the top three answers were reported most
of the questions allowed for multiple
answers and some of the questions were
designed for agencies providers or
contractors and not applicable for a
physician or a research entity
so here are some of the analysis
findings in respect to hiv sdi
prevention needs for msm the majority of
respondents indicated that young msm
population should be the top priority
followed by risk reduction and more
awareness of stis
differences in ethnic and cultural needs
clients fear of rejection
stigma and no one message fits all msm
were reported the most as barriers to
providing msm disease prevention
services
when it comes to interventions
considered as not being successful
poorly crafted message
one-size-fits-all approach and
limitations around the design of the
interventions were considered the most
significant
inadequate approaches by respondents
lack of lgbt community leadership
poor outreach job done locally and the
difficulty of reaching the msn community
where the top response is considered to
be challenges of providing hiv sti
prevention services to msm
in the area of having the ideal capacity
for the implementation of execution of
hiv sti prevention services for msm
respondents indicated that funds was a
major factor recruitment of volunteers
and the addition of more staff
staff as their top needs
in regards to increasing the capacity
at a statewide level responders
considered that a mass campaign
workshops among providers and the state
working closer with providers were the
most important areas to be targeted
as far as the hiv sta prevention
services that respondents would like to
offer to the msm in their respective
communities community outreach risk
reduction and basic outreach were the
top three answers
trends experienced by msm in connecticut
reported as being priorities by
providers where the risk of using
internet websites for hookups followed
by the risk associated with the use of
recreational drugs at parties and a
young msm sti diagnosis pattern as we
heard earlier
it was recommended by providers the need
of a change in perceptions by the msn
community reporting as equally important
in three areas increasing the
self-esteem of msm
that sdi can happen to anyone and
educating msm about safe sex being an
option
this assessment concluded a need for a
more cohesive approach where agencies
around the state come together and
exchange ideas a need for capacity
building assistance training for
providers on the issues related to
providing hiv sti prevention services to
msm
a need for new strategies to reach msm
with prevention messages including the
use of technological innovations such as
the internet and cell phone applications
and the need to address cultural racial
ethnic and social challenges of
providing hiv sti prevention services to
msm
this assessment contributes
significantly to understanding the msm
gear hiv sti prevention services
barriers and needs in the state of
connecticut and provides a foundation
for future recommendations of effective
interventions for msm in connecticut
muchas gracias